this episode of GameSpot's Holiday Gift
Guide is presented by Sony Entertainment
Network get $15 credit for spending $100
visit sony.com/howdini Gift Guide I'm
Jeff kanata our focus in this episode is
the gamer on your list who doesn't just
stick to the mainstream this is someone
tied in to the most exciting vibrant and
unconventional side of gaming culture
right now indie gaming let's start with
one of the most unusual games of the
year
oh hokum how do I describe the
experience of this game you play as a
long flying snake-like creature called
the long mover you're flying through
space affecting the environment in a
variety of ways burying your friends
from place to place experiencing this
dreamlike landscape bursting with
imagination it's unlike anything else
out there the color palette the imagery
it's all bright and joyous and since its
cross by your indie gamer can enjoy it
on the ps4 or the Vita on the other side
of the spectrum the swapper feels dark
brooding and isolated within a
fantastically atmospheric way alone on
an alien world you discover a strange
device that allows you to create copies
of yourself you'll use this ability to
explore the world and solve the game's
wonderfully inventive puzzles and
platforming challenges the world is
beautiful and mysterious and the game is
available on the PC Xbox Playstation and
Vita
one of the coolest games I played all
year big or small was transistor from
supergiant games these are the guys that
created one of my favorite indie games
of all time
Bastion like Bastion it tells its story
using voiceover and discovery in really
interesting ways transistor is available
for ps4 PC and Mac home is a pixel art
adventure game reminiscent of classics
like King's Quest and Secret of Monkey
Island but one of those games challenge
your mind and your funny bone home will
test your nerve home is a horror themed
murder mystery you got a venture deep
into the darkness to piece together
clues and survive and you'll not believe
how Keira fiying some simple pixel art
can be but nothing screams indie game
more than Octodad dadliest catch from
young heroes it's available for PC and
ps4 in the game you control the
eponymous Octodad who is an octopus
desperately trying to hide the fact that
he isn't human from his family you
control octodad's boneless tentacle arms
with the analog sticks but it isn't easy
and you'll find yourself being as clumsy
inept and silly as you might expect an
oxygen breathing octopus wearing a suit
to be on land this game exemplifies the
indie spirit so there you have it five
great indie titles sure to spark the
imagination challenge the reflexes and
question the status quo in mainstream
gaming if you've got a gamer on your
list who loves the indie scene or even
just one excited to try something
different you can't go wrong with any of
these picks
i'm jeff kannada thanks for watching